hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday August [ __ ] 27th August 27th
what's going on how are you as you know
I don't have a lot of guests on on my
podcast every once in a while I'll have
someone that interests me I'm an
eleventh chair I'm not like constantly
farting here I'm just adjusting my
weight I have one of my oldest friends
in this business I've known this man
since 1995 when we were a couple of
nobodies going around [ __ ] New York
trying to get spots he has his name I'll
just introduce you
unbelievable comedian mr. Tom pop
everybody nice to be here bill 95 that's
amazing so I was only doing stand-up for
two years when we miss that right you
were already really good 93 I wasn't
good I was loud
I was loud and fast well I remember
Geraldo rest his soul you can tell me
that the way you used to stand on stage
you were in some sort of like warrior
one or warrior two it was sort of weird
lean I would I called it the lunge
wasn't lunge
I would like lean yeah I would kind of
like been my one leg and kind of lunged
that way and talked to that part of the
audience then it would lunge the other
way talk to I bet it got laughs oh yeah
I thought they'd probably like he's a
character he's thinking a character we
can build a sitcom around this guy look
he's a young guy like back then that was
the whole thing long bushy curly hair
uh-huh um probably about 25 pounds
heavier than I am now oh you a heavier
yeah and are you a party in back then it
was like my crazy my wife calls it when
she saw a tape of it no no she didn't
know me back then she saw me probably 10
years after that and when she saw I
don't know if you have like a good tape
of you when you first started but
there's like they're all so classic and
she saw it and said it looked like my
crazy brother showed up in came to town
and started doing comedy you're Roger
Clinton showed up right I did kind of
look Roger Clinton this had that kind of
almost a mullet but not really I got one
in
I forget where the hell I was I was
doing some local Boston show yeah I mean
it was taped someone's gotta have to
tape somewhere and and I was wearing
basically the clothes that I wore to the
dental office that day I was still
working them I was definitely wearing
the pants so I had like powder from the
rubber gloves and God knows how much
germs on me because I like the only way
to make the gig was I had to work and
then just jump in my car go so I brought
it share a chair a brush shirt so I had
I had on navy blue Dockers and then I
had a shirt it was navy blue striped and
like like pea soup green horizontal
stripes
I had a big red afro tucked in and shirt
tucked in no no grunts had already hit
at that point nice so I started at 92 so
it was already like right he was already
going so it was like if you tucked in
your shirt you you were part of the
eighties oh good so this sure I believe
was untucked might not have been now
that I think about it but I was I just
remember I was pointing at the crowd
when I was like like anunciacion I was
doing this thing remember when I did
that thing you fired that little snake
thing here with his hand and they made
fun of it so much he stopped doing it
right which is kind of funny to think
about now that's interesting though you
with the pointing as you're telling the
jokes I mean with the lunging yes
because the two guys that I wanted to be
kind of badass like I didn't want to be
like them but I can look back and think
like Bill Hicks and Denis Leary would
get in the audience's face and they
would kind of like jab at them kind of
that way oh okay were you watching those
guys at that time I didn't even know who
Bill Hicks was until after he died oh
really
well I mean because Bill Hicks was not
getting on mainstream stuff he had done
a couple of Letterman's but back then
you know if he didn't know to look for
him if you missed his lettering spot you
just missed it I found him by mistake on
Caroline's Comedy Hour
oh okay in a Caroline's comedy hour when
Caroline's was down in another location
I think about a seaport or something
before our time then I saw him and he
would get like right in their face he
would at the edge of the stage he'd bend
all the way down with a cigarette from
his face and yell about Britney Spears
or whatever
now he was gone before Britney Spears I
just felt at that time like you have no
material so you just you know you're
funny but you have no real skill you got
some stuff but then it's just pure
energy it's just well that I think that
that's because I was totally like in a
very but so that was me just sort of I
think was just that was me I was miming
throwing [ __ ] against the wall I think
every joke that I was doing but then as
we came up through the ranks what amazed
me about you was the way that you could
like always work totally clean and like
you I mean you know we came up you know
SD would be giving us the late spots
that's how it is you got to earn you got
to earn the earlier ones yeah and I
regard free crushing you know all of
these guys you go on at the my filth and
you go out there just totally sportcoat
on sweeping clean and just bugged you
just killed I did go through some phases
when especially when I got to the cellar
uh-huh where I was you know going up
after it's hell where for a good month I
thought I've got to be dirtier I've got
a yeah I've got to do something so I
started coming up with filthier stuff
and I'm telling you just the audience
knew they don't know me at all yeah that
is not this guy they knew I was not the
guy saying these words like it wasn't it
did not fit you know what's funny is
what you're saying right now is all you
had to say after Dave yeah like I'd like
to continue right in that dark world but
look at me folks I'm not that guy yeah I
didn't have the courage or like the the
wherewithal to do that so my only cure
for it was don't watch anybody before I
go on just completely stay alone and
wait for them to come and get me like
last minute like hey they're calling
your name and then go down
isn't that amazing no but I think people
that are successful will find ways you
know in situations like that they
actually come up they'll come up with
their own sort of exercise yeah
to belie right well if I just don't see
it then I I don't have to like deal with
it yeah and some way to preserve
whatever you got to kind of do I did
something last week when I was on Conan
right uh-huh I did something that I
learned at the Comedy Cellar it was a
Comedy Cellar
as small as it is yeah it always seems
so gigantic to me right because it was
like this place she wanted to get into s
T would be watching your sets the
[ __ ] waitstaff would report ya back
to management and [ __ ] and you just
never felt like you know it takes a good
eight years before you feel like you're
in it totally so I remember
Patrice had done something on stage I
don't know what happened yeah he had
done something so they called a meeting
this is [ __ ] hilarious they call this
meeting to get the Comedy Cellar okay
and the three people showed up out of
all the comics it was me and Bobby I was
looking with Bobby Kelly buddies like
dude we got to go to the meeting dude
it's gonna take away our spots dude and
I'm like I know you and we both went
down there freaking frack to Boston guys
we go down there it was us too and Dave
Attell oh my god Patrice who the whole
[ __ ] meeting was about didn't even
show up of course and everybody else was
kind of in a zag again a [ __ ] going
down there but names we went in there
and I remember waiting for SD and Manny
to get their rest his soul and I just
was I was apps it was the middle of the
day and I could not believe how small
the club was right and I was just like
oh my god I mean I could literally move
all the chairs out of here in 11 minutes
by myself it is yeah which sometimes
I'll go down to go to use the restroom
even now and you go down there and it's
just empty and everything's pushed aside
so they can mop and it really is like a
closet and it's because when I don't
know what it is about that room yeah
when it gets full it's mad and yes and
it just but it be it becomes this other
this energy thing that you just saw and
then when it's everybody's gone yeah and
they're like going like this is this
place it's like you know yeah so anyway
so I went I had to go do Conan and I
just so happened I was ready for once
before the you know right as the guy got
there to pick you up so I got there like
15 minutes early there was nobody there
so I was like you know I always just
walked out there when I just walk out
and take a look at it yeah just so I can
really have in my head how big it is
oh nice you know it was still pretty big
I mean but it wasn't like but it was
your space I wanted to be more grounded
right so I went up I looked at the drum
kit and stuff sat down played for like
two seconds and then like walked around
talked to a couple of people few people
said hello
yeah and then it just kind of felt like
and I was just looking so smart
yeah Thanks so smart yes so cuz even
when you leave you've done the show a
bunch but when you could walk back out
it feels new again it's not yet home yes
so I did the new again thing before the
cameras were on nice and then so then
when I went out there I felt like I was
you know the most present I didn't have
that same outer body experience where
afterwards I had I would always look at
Andy and be like was that good like like
basically what happened I totally
because the whole time you're doing it
you're thinking like nowadays too it's
yeah did I just end my [ __ ] career
what did I say you know is this group
gonna come at me or fat people gonna say
this like you know all of that [ __ ] so
anyway speaking of careers yes you are
on this podcast not because you like me
well not because you wanted to come over
here and smoke a cigar afterwards what's
up finding out you don't have time with
Tom papa
not only an incredible comedian you also
bake your own bread yes I do what you've
been doing for years I mean you you were
actually nice enough to offer to teach
me and I've just never found time to get
over there and I brought you bread like
a year ago you remember I brought it up
like 2 times I vaguely remember because
it's gone that quick it brings it over
in a little basket with this old lady
little towel over the top of it you're
like like you don't even need butter you
made us a what did you make us I always
get a sour sourdough yeah oh good stuff
I got kutami ania basically ate the
whole loaf talking about what we were
gonna eat it with that night not the
whole day we were like we got to finish
this so now all of a sudden yeah your
professional and your hobby life have
now blurred here and you have
new cooking show coming out today I
guess right Monday a week a week from
Labor Day a Labor days a week from today
what's the exact date September 3rd so
Thursday 10 o'clock at night 10 o'clock
East called baked
it's called baked no you're not putting
any weed in the bread man a man yeah
it's not really a cooking show as much
as a food show like I'm not gonna go I
guess I'm I guess I am cooking basically
what I did it's not to be 8 episodes of
watching you cook bread no okay exactly
that's uh that's kind of what I thought
it was gonna be and they're like this is
gonna be over in an episode yeah do you
have a hundred different kinds of loaves
of bread gonna make so we can get that
to syndication so what I was doing I
started baking it I started getting
really good at it and when I would
travel around on the road doing stand-up
during the day I would visit bakeries I
would go check them out and I was just
trying to learn like see what flour they
were using talk to them that kind of
thing yeah you got into it I got into it
and they caught wind of it and thought
it would be a cool show because I'm
already doing it I'm going to these
places and then you know I'm going to
learn I'm super curious about it and
they didn't have any show that just
dealt with baked goods can you back up
for a second how did they catch wind of
it I have that Alexis in your [ __ ]
house or something how do they catch
wind you're a comic killing a day and
you're going to bakeries because I've
started talking about it on social media
I talked about it on Rogen's podcast I
talked about it on Conan and okay in the
New York Times did a an article on
people with sourdough starters you know
the sourdough starter is the the little
mother the mother I hate that I hate it
this I saw the thing that there's like a
thing in France that some of them had
they're like they're like a couple
hundred years old yeah like you just
keep feeding it some sort of bacteria no
you just keep feeding it flour and in
water and it eats it and that stays
alive yeah it's the active yeast in
there and so you got a feed of flour and
water and it eats it and so it's like
they've had a goldfish that they've been
feeding
like the last since like the early 1800s
yeah and it's a little vague like when
people say it's a hundred years old I
mean cuz you like nobody ever spilt it
it has its origin like it has it you
will have a it will connect to however
long you've been feeding it but you're
dumping a lot of it and then new flour
and water is going in but I'm just a
cool story yeah you know and now I feel
like a novice and people do care about
it people do like hang on to them pass
them down to other people in their
family and it is a thing like you might
have two of them and they're in my
refrigerator and I've been on the road
now for a week I just got home today and
I know and I leave you I'm gonna get
home and feed them because it's been a
week if you don't feed it it slowly
starts to become less active it has no
food to eat and then it starts creating
its own alcohol and that's it when you
come back it'll be like a layer of
alcohol on top of it
now I'm so Looch you're like a
microbrewery yeah exactly
oh it's literally called who literally
that way help your alcohol please that
call hooch yeah it's a fermentation this
is already the most informative podcast
I've ever done that's [ __ ] awesome
so the New York Times did an article on
people with their sourdough starters and
just you know I've been doing it for
like a year and they came into my house
and took pictures of me with my starter
and I was in the food section this is
I'm not doing anything showbizzy with
this I'm just baking bread with my
daughter it's a mint always how comes
about when you're not trying not at all
and my friends back east with the New
York Times and they're calling me like
what are you doing what's what are you
in the food section so it just became a
thing and then people started sending me
things on Twitter and Facebook or
whatever showing me that there are
attempts at baking like and that's a
massive subculture yeah of it's not even
just people who bake like specifically
baked bread yeah people who are into
Bourbons like there's all these
subculture thing that when when you all
of a sudden get into it totally yeah you
just be like open the door a little bit
all of a sudden you see there's like you
know a million people in there like
yeah so yeah you're like wow look at all
these Instagram accounts of people doing
what I'm yeah so is it just kind of took
off and was super fun and I also at the
same time that I started baking it I
also started getting on this kick of
this is why are we the first generation
it bread has been around for thousands
of years why are we the generation
that's being told we shouldn't eat bread
why all of a sudden are we now like no
you're the new human beings that can eat
bread and I was like there's something
wrong here and then when we started
baking this bread it's just flour water
salt and yeast that's all it's in it and
when the bread I would buy my daughters
in the supermarket trying to get them
good bread had 30 ingredients in it
right chemicals sugars glucose all of
Isis Isis and I started giving that
bread to my friends that have problems
with eating bread and they had no
problems we were eating a lot of bread
and we weren't getting fat and I was
like this is the pure thing this is what
bread really is so then I started going
off on this kick in my act and it
started you know permeating other parts
of what was in my book where I was just
like we should be allowed to celebrate
in life we should be allowed Kanon can I
pitch an episode yes an episode cuz you
got a tour in the can okay your next
season mmm
Tom teaches bill how to bake bread or
even just a great even just for the
website that would be awesome
because I am on this new diet that I've
been doing for like the last three weeks
and I've been you know keeping the
muscle and dropping all the fat and I
love how I look and everything but it's
just like you know I come I can't have a
piece of bread every once in a while
every once in a while and you eat I do
what okay
I'll do the [ __ ] that I used to you know
you're part of my generation I always
Wonder Bread my son stay comes on Wonder
Bread and the grease would be going
who the brand you have to eat it quick
before we went through oh yeah you know
how to fork or something I and I stand
by dude I I had that today I would have
to take a nap immediately but it would
be effing delicious in a child sense
memory foam button your stuff yeah I ate
you up Brett I was like I gotta call my
parents I mean it was just it was just
like it was like a wholesome yeah
holidays everything that like you know
when when all the BS slows down in life
right you know you just got past
something or maybe it's the holidays you
got a few days off you just have time
but you actually have free time to hang
with the people in your life and you're
like oh this is what it's it's so creepy
right exactly this is what it could be
and it's not every day I mean these are
special moments in your life you know
I mean basically the way the show goes
is I I just pictured you talking to your
family like don't get you there's bread
in the house all the time now like when
I go on the road if I'm gone for a while
they get for the first time they call me
like when you coming back and it's not
because they want to see do you realize
your kids they're gonna talk about you
like some like grandmother from the
early 1900s going yeah
there was always the smell of bread in
our house I'm out I always remember her
I remember her when she passed the
casket smelled like sorry I shoulda said
bread it just took a whole nother angle
on there so what's your favorite uh so
so so basically I go around to all these
different cities I come into a city and
I visit five of the best baked goods I
can find a bakery a sandwich place with
amazing rolls a pizza place whatever it
is what hangs I've been dealing with
dough and that kind of thing and you
quickly realize this back to it being
special you quickly realize there
doesn't there's no need for a bakery in
a town you know what I mean like there's
you need the cops you need the fire
department you need the power you need
the the water you need all this stuff a
bakery is a special little place that
just happens to be at the town that when
you're want to
yourself or get something nice for your
family that's when you go to the bakery
it's this nice little celebration in
your everyday life you don't go there
every day you know most of the time so
all these people are creating this
really special stuff and you go in there
and you feel good and that you should be
celebrating your light like this is it
like this we're not going to this this
is prime time right this is when we're
really going to enjoy ourselves you take
your daughter and walk into a bakery and
give her a cookie that is a special
moment that's a special thing you know
when she's when she turned a
year-and-a-half last month I actually I
went to a bakery and I bought her a
cupcake and put one and a half candles
in it and sang happy one and a half oh
my god she's just looking at me like
when can I eat this nice song dad I
don't know what's going on here kid one
thing can I have that yeah this is
special for you but I really feel like
it's it's just it's a celebration life
should be a celebration you don't eat
this stuff all the time you don't want
to you know you you want to be in shape
you don't want to get diabetes but you
should enjoy it all right we'll do an
episode I'll teach you how to make a pie
crust you teach me how to make baked
some Brent and that would be great we
should do it
that's all you know so I gotta be honest
with you like I just the whole idea
having a comedian who bakes you know
it's weird right
no I'm just saying like what a homerun
for a show oh right and then you're
gonna go check out all these cool
bakeries like I don't know I've had
diners drive it in the dives it just
seems like everybody's always eating
like the burgers the tacos the burritos
the pizza yeah they've had all of those
shows but I haven't seen a guy Baker do
the bakeries know and like you know for
years yeah I've been you know sort of
like gay-bashed in a way that I actually
know how to bake they make pies and
stuff but I'm like why it's awesome and
women love you I do know how to bake
like they love Oh completely there's a
whole there was a whole article about
women that get turned on by these guys
that bake bread
remember we're solutely it's like it's
it's like having a saint for me because
I'm such an [ __ ]
it
it takes down a lot of my [ __ ] that I do
you know you know what's the edge of ya
make a scene at the supercar plz
shutting people off but he bakes a hell
of a pie even your voice changed it
makes a hell of a [ __ ] take some of the
edge off
you uh you brought a pie was it last
Christmas was it around the holidays I
can't remember brought me a pie and the
center wasn't cooked and you also you
were so bummed out I'm I tell you what
cuz we were renting a house cuz I don't
like [ __ ] one fixed up yeah and what
happened was the door was slightly ajar
and let the heat up no I made you I'm
still remember send me a picture of it I
made yeah cuz I felt so bad I made you
pumpkin bread for Halloween yeah that's
right and it's the easiest [ __ ] thing
yes just a concoction you pour it in the
thing you throw at the oven and you're
done
and you leave it yeah and it wasn't done
so I had to tell you to put it back in
and you were able to fix it though but I
was I was so embarrassed and then the
fact that you're like this you know me
such a good Baker you're in the food
section of the times I get a couple of
hits on you know Facebook when I make a
pie but but you know what I remember
distinctly like we just ate around the
raw part and it was delicious thank you
that's the cool thing like you don't
realize you mess this stuff up I still
screw up breads because it takes it's a
three day process and if you mess up
along the way you're gonna get a flat
frisbee but I'm telling you the flat
frisbee is delicious yeah just cuz it
doesn't look good just put some butter
on it you just oh yeah what do you been
up to as far as you've been traveling
the road promoting the show you've been
doing some dates what he been up to a
day yeah it's it's not really slowed
down I have I had five jobs from April
until just recently
mm-hmm where I was doing my stand-up of
course and then I had a book come out so
I had to tour around with the book I
took over the writing for live from here
which was Prairie Home Companion mm-hmm
garrison retired and Kristy Lee took
over as the host and I
over the comedy of it and the writing of
it and I also do a monologue each week
on it and then and then I have my
podcast I come to pop a podcast and
radio show for serious and and then
baked and then when they when the red
show came you know as happens in
production they are like yeah we might
make it we might make it and then like
we bought eight in a month so on top of
touring with the radio show and with my
stand-up and the book tour the bread
show got thrown on top of it so so the
bread show you're probably thinking it's
ain't gonna go it's a fun little thing
that I'll do it's fine we'll do do pilot
roll me a couple of bucks this is cool
we'll do a pilot who knows you know I
wasn't the the beautiful part of this is
I have no showbiz anxiety about this I
still don't
I still don't I everything else you know
you make stuff you sell it you try and
get it on the air you push yeah but else
I think if you tore a comic and you have
your own podcast you're making enough
money that I don't have any showbiz
stress where I love doing my TV show
absolutely love doing it but like I'm
not like in the unemployment line right
if it doesn't go yeah if it doesn't go
which I hope it goes by the way
anybody's listening yeah industry drone
out - he's not appreciating - Cheryl
yeah but this show I completely I'm like
look we can do a show about it that'd be
great I'd love to share with more people
that that's awesome if you don't make a
show about it I'm still gonna go to the
bakery in Cleveland when I get there you
know what I mean so how much time did
you but did you have to carve out his
feds schedule and keep doing it I just
threw it on top of everything else so
while I was doing the book tour while I
was doing the stand-up I was doing all
this other stuff I was doing episodes of
this show that are gonna start airing
and I literally have not been in my home
for a full week since April oh my god
yeah it would just it just all it was
like a tsunami everything a perfect
storm it all just hit at the same time
how do you handle that I just go I just
go and
the having a family is an a you know I
want to be with them and literally bill
my kids are 16 and 13 now and I was like
I literally before all of this stuff hit
the fan I literally said to myself I'm
gonna be smarter about how I tore these
are the there's were only a couple more
years here before everybody starts
taking off on their own I'm gonna be
around a little bit more yeah and boom
as soon as I said it I was gone huh
and so that's that's the industry are
you young people in the industry just
say out loud you know what I'm gonna
move back east just say that now the
showbiz uniform universe will let you
move back east yeah then it'll get you
something after you've given up your
apartment and all that do that just
happy was that just happen at Dien del
rey oh yeah Dean del Rey psych I'm
getting all these C's bicoastal now
anybody so he went to New York like I'm
gonna be out there for a while doing
spots a minute the cellar about dude he
gets he's there for like two weeks they
got Conan no he just got caught he's
gonna come back it's actually he's on
Conan tonight with Marc Maron oh nice
I'm gonna try to go over there for the
put the taping yeah that'll be fun
things he's such a good guy he's got and
Dean you know I haven't watched him that
much but over the last you know several
years he just got you just some guys
just turned the corner
they just know exactly what they're
starting to do like he got so tuned into
his voice yeah he's just he's DS on so
HN off stage yeah he's a killer now now
he opens for me he gets he gets like
sustained rounds of applause when he's
done dude I had to go on after him and
Todd Rex you ever go on at the Todd rec
no [ __ ] monster oh really yeah and
both you know Todd has this thing look
did people love him yeah like he's one
of these he's like a big kid kids love
him adults love him right and he is like
he's like a legit headliner wow those
guys are before you yeah I did what's
good is though but then people come out
like and they get to see like a full
show yeah it's rather than some like you
know some cupcake you put on in front of
it's up there it's been crazy yeah
you'll notice with raindrops somewhat
bigger than others I did a show last
night in in or the other night in
Michigan northern Michigan and it was
this Performing Arts Center this nice
theater beautiful place up and like I've
never been that decent bakery nice
bakery no opener no I just walked out
and just did it it was kind of lonely
like hanging out during the day and
stuff but I have to say it was kind of
you have to do more time you know you're
doing more like an hour and a half but
uh I really liked it I will do that yeah
well I do like ninety minutes anyway on
top of those guys yeah but if I have one
guy he does like 15 if I have two guys
they both do ten okay and I'm trying
like but you ever just walk out you ever
just go with nobody yes have I done
nobody on the road I only a few times
yeah it might create becomes a different
thing it is a different thing I think it
would be weird at a club yes
just because with a club there's so much
commotion going on yeah and there's so
many drinks you got to get out so much
food to get out and all the [ __ ] all
that
pomp and circumstance has to happen yeah
there's a lot going on and then when the
headliner comes on it's like now we have
your undivided attention until we drop
all the checks yeah so there's always
commotion going on with the clubs but
like at a theater I think if he comes an
evening with rather than yeah a show
like I saw uh who did I see I saw Billy
Connelly
uh-huh I saw him in New York about ten
years ago and if I remember yeah cuz he
did like two hours yeah he did two
[ __ ] hours it was unbelievable and
like at that point that's when guys were
kind of like if you did like an hour it
was like wow yeah do you ever want a
headlining was 45 minutes yeah everybody
did 45 45 that's yeah insane [ __ ]
joke insane
I feel like now if I don't do like an
hour and 20 I'm ripping them off I don't
know and no yeah it's a weird thing you
know what's weird about it too is that
it's kind of like when you do push ups
like if you say you're gonna do 20
push-ups 18 19 20 are really hard if you
tell yourself you're doing 25 all of a
sudden 23 24 25 are hard like it's all
about that it's either hard 25 is gonna
see like a [ __ ] zillion miles away
but I know what I mean you know if you
shootin yeah at just your head your head
does something you say I'm gonna go do
an hour and a half tonight yeah that's
just the way it is if you say you're
doing an hour all of a sudden you're
panting to get to an hour all right hey
you want to answer some questions here
you want to help me out I give people
advice on this this podcast of course
you know if any of this is gonna ruin
your bread show just let me know I'll
give you so last week I somebody
mentioned that you know actually my dumb
ass I went on like I was like let's see
what's going on in the world oh no and I
don't know if I want to drag you into
this but like Trump said that said
they're killing white farmers in South
Africa which is gonna happen if what I
never condoned it I didn't say it wasn't
a big deal I was just I was talking
about what he pays attention to uh-huh
which you know I don't think if they
were Puerto Rican farmers he would give
a [ __ ] and I am call me a reverse racist
but I am basing that on the fact that
when there was regular people and then
neo-nazis involved he was sitting there
going like well you know you can kind of
see both sides of the story yeah so
anyways
yeah so this guy wrote a brought in from
Cape Town so we got a bunch of people
from Europe all right say no but blood
but blood yeah they're just like me then
they're not there right so we didn't
listen to them all right so this guy's
from Cape Town right there
how's it going Billy I'm from Cape Town
South Africa I'm a big fan I listen to
your podcast every week yeah do ya you
gotta care for a visit
yeah I thought I'd love to go there I'd
go there I have two topics I want to put
out there first my country got some
airtime in the news last week due to a
tweet by the Donald guy now just a recap
and I don't know what this guy's tone is
but I've read some of the other ones
they're all like why don't you [ __ ]
read about it before you open your mouth
alright now just to recap he basically
mentioned investigating farm murders and
land expropriation without payment in
South Africa based on race why are we
getting involved in this yeah I know why
are we getting invited I bet one of the
farmers was gonna sell him land to build
a golf course we have to stop it
alright news outlets like BBC CNN etc
were quick to point out that these
claims were baseless and then if you
look at the crime stats you would
actually see a decline in the farm based
attacks I don't look I don't watch you
got into it because Tucker Carlson did a
thing on it no I do you know what the I
should cuz I don't watch the news yeah
cuz all does it give me eggs it's just
it's a half-hour of anxiety with no
solution yeah and all this [ __ ] that I
wasn't worried about I now have to add
to the [ __ ] I already was worried about
so why would I do it to set the record
state I can tell you that if you search
deeper and speak to the average South
African they would tell you a different
story
being a farmer or farm worker is by far
the most dangerous job you can have
around here due to the number of attacks
and the cold blood are blooded barbaric
nature of these attacks there is no
doubt that the number of attacks has
grown a number and in in brutality in
recent years yet these attacks are not
widely reported and the accuracy of the
statistics on the farmers have been a
point of dispute ever since the end of
apartheid anyone you talk to yeah the
whole [ __ ] thing is there was brutal
attacks to get the land and then a
brutal form of government and now
there's a brutal reaction to it it's my
limited understanding to it and I'm not
saying any of that was right I was just
saying it's interesting what all the
orange headed lunatic decides to pay
attention to right exactly he's all I'm
saying I mean this is and I've even said
the last election was 2 a.m. at a bar
you had to go home with somebody you
didn't want to leave with either one but
you had to leave with somebody so I'm
not I am not picking a side politically
arraign that should anyways anyone you
talk to can tow tell you of multiple
multiple of their close friends or
relatives we've been attacked have been
affected by an attack regardless of race
race yet this is not helped by the fact
that many political rallies are met with
chants of
kill the Bora the farmer killed a farmer
these political parties are basically
garnering support on the false promise
of land and wealth to everyone
yay communism what do you mean yay
communism that happened in our country
yeah man we got a repeal against these
English guys and then all the rich [ __ ]
once we kicked them out moved into the
rich guys houses right and continued the
taxes this is I love what they blamed
forms of government yeah is there a form
of government that works I don't think
there is because every because you get
at the end that you have human beings
with unchecked power on some level at
the top and it's just that's right oh
yeah some people taste the good life and
they don't want to give it back no no
that's what's going on Nicaragua right
now what's going about someone else's
problems it's basically the students are
rioting and trying to take the
government back and the guy who they're
trying to take the government back took
the government for the people when he
was a student but then he got fat and
happy and now he's like the dictator who
doesn't want to let it go yeah whenever
any whenever you taste the good life
nobody wants to let it go no you get the
extra food you get the best booze the
best women oh my God all of it and shake
my silk robe yeah yeah people are
cooking your meals yeah he's sitting in
the hot tub yeah you gonna get out of
that thing to go help somebody less
fortunate than you no that's not how
people are wired no they put up gates
around their home yeah and they say I'm
gonna keep this this yeah I agree
I'll read more about this stuff I'll
definitely look up what I get but you
know but why but but back to your thing
about the orange guy pointing this out
bringing us into like I understand
that's a big problem when you read about
it's like oh boy this is a mess don't we
have our own messes like darn I'm like
why do I have to jump into this one I
mean there's stuff like that no yes you
would be the human being yeah you're
supposed to care you do care but I can't
how much time you know you could care
about everything we get the Nicaragua
thing is a huge thing I mean it's I
don't know it's going there all I know
is this country is [ __ ] bankrupt and
because we're fighting a war that has no
set ending and you're not allowed to ask
about it and I don't wanna bring this
[ __ ] up we got a [ __ ] show coming out
it's just one of those things what's
just like I don't understand why if I
ask like hey how are we gonna pay for
this hey won't be coming back all of a
sudden I don't support the troops I'm
not American
right and I just became like I just got
my I'm part of Isis now yeah I can do
that I was talking about it I love the
Patriots I can sit there be like what
the [ __ ] are we doing why did we draft
that guy people just go don't go like
you're not a Patriots fan you like the
Jets you're a piece of [ __ ]
so it's a very weird it's a weird time
yeah because there's a bunch of people
afraid to say stuff that we everybody
kind of agrees with yeah but don't you
think also that there's a lot of real
like reasonable people that are thinking
the same thing you are on whatever issue
thinking the same thing and when you do
bring it up they agree and quietly go
about their day like normal people they
come up after the show after they didn't
laugh and say yeah I you're 100% right
on the bubble I totally agree with this
or I had a dad just like that or
whatever the [ __ ] that you were talking
about that made the fabric quiet it's a
deep I you know what it really is I
can't believe how many people are afraid
to get in trouble
yeah like basically get yelled at on
Twitter right by who by who
yeah it's the loudest the loudest one
yeah right it's just that's what I'm
saying there's so many more people that
aren't tweeting hateful stuff at you I
think most of it has to do with a
corporation god forbid if one extra
nickel that they could have made rolled
out the [ __ ] door
that's the only time they do the
customer is always right is with that
[ __ ] right everything else you can go
[ __ ] yourself you can go to the website
and stare at the screen and try and
figure it out yourself and maybe you'll
get a portion of a refund or something I
don't want to get all gloom and doom
here with this stuff so let's let's talk
sports man I was really watching the Red
Sox and then I just thought you would
like this is the regular season man I
know but it has been
Oh Jake I'm a Yankee fan right it is by
the way congratulations
it's must have been a fun ride your
whole life it wasn't when I was a kid
well I had a little Greg nettles Reggie
Jackson when I was really little and
then I had to go the whole 80s without
his world series guys do you realize if
you guys don't win it this year or next
year that is the only second time you
haven't won a World Series during a
decade yeah use the level of success
that that is is [ __ ] ridiculous not to
mention I think two decades you want at
least half of them in the 40s and 50s
well yeah but I mean I can't who knows
what was going on back then there was a
bobby socks and Frank Sinatra when
during my time right we went through
horrible periods when they were like
trying to buy people and we never in the
was always messed up but the Jeter years
homegrown kids great that's because you
got it I got kicked out of baseball and
he would have got rid of half of them I
don't think Jeter and I don't think he
would have known what you would Mariano
Rivera was gonna because nobody did cuz
you guys had him pitching like no but
it'll relief O'Neal would have been gone
Bernie Williams would have been gone
well O'Neal you got from the Reds they
wouldn't they would not have hung on to
these people he was but it was homegrown
it was it was pure I have a guilt I have
a guilt as a Yankee fan when you buy and
you know you've got Johnny Damon all of
a sudden steely Alfia I don't like that
money part of it oh wait we're on it
right over the cliff with it yeah and
we're like I well they're in our
division this is how you play so now you
guys are doing it the right way we're
doing it the right way in a great season
I love baseball right my favorite sport
and I'm enjoying the hell out of a young
guys scraping enjoying it the
second-best record in all of baseball
and we can't get close to the Red Sox
but this is what's great though
what is so great is the greed of
baseball where now they have to have
nine million rounds like back in the day
if we slept swept you in August yeah
that would have been a big thing but
back in the day I would have been as a
Red Sox fan like ok how they gonna [ __ ]
it up this time they always did but that
would immense
something yes that didn't really mean
anything because because how it doesn't
mean it yeah because you guys are gonna
get the wild card
we'll get one game playoff against
Oakland or something and we'll lose and
be out one game it's why don't you know
I don't like the one what's the one game
thing well we have the one game the one
game playoff also they added that and
then it's the three game and then the
fours and then the four right yeah but
guys doing up there what you never you
never lose you never lose how many wins
do they have last night you say they
were like 91 and 41 or and yeah we just
need 40 worried so but no we're tonight
I didn't I Tim I didn't well I'm taping
this Sunday night just so don't confuse
are you guys as good are you guys as
good as this record you know no nobody
ever is your regular-season record is
never as good as you are because you're
you're rolling up all these stats on
people who aren't gonna be there in
October so what you have to do is you
got to look at like we just played we
just played the Indians who I think
Terry Francona is still the best manager
in baseball everybody's sleeping on them
nobody gets more out of it plays in this
[ __ ] guy and we played a four-game
series we split it the first two games
he made us look like a 500 ball club and
then our big free agent guys you know
sale and price came in and shut him down
right okay now here's the thing you
[ __ ] like Houston they got Ferland I
got almost got visit offending good
nobody's talking about they're so good
exactly and they probably had a couple
of injuries and whatever but ba-ba-ba-ba
all I know is come October we're all 0
and 0
I think clearly there might pick 2 to
take it again and what ESPN does about
regular seasons is what the news does
about like Isis where in my head Isis
was powerful enough to come over here
attack this country and overthrow it
right until I actually sat down I was
like they don't have a plane or a boat
or uniforms this is not Germany and
Japan again ok
so [ __ ] they do the same thing what
they basically said the race was over
when we swept you guys four games in a
[ __ ]
no we do we have like 12 games left yeah
injuries happen to try and get to the
one on the 18th or 19th so I dude I have
done this too many times he's a sports
fan
- no you try to put my feet up in August
amen say anything's over I watched a
slow 12 game lead like I don't know how
many years ago four or five years ago
yeah I watched this below that classic
18 game lead in 78 yeah I've seen the
Tuck rule I've seen the the [ __ ] I've
seen it all doing this fat and roughing
the passer there's still that lit
insecure I've been beaten by my eyeballs
rolled through guys legs it's so great I
was at dinner with my brother-in-law and
his wife the other night and Red Sox
fans and there's literally when we were
talking they were still nine and a half
up but it was the Cleveland and they've
lost the first game at Cleveland and the
Yankees won that night and we got a half
game up and I was like here it comes
here comes the slide this is the
beginning of again and I was just
talking out of my ass cuz they're so
solid but the fear in my
brother-in-law's eyes like oh man it
really is this is the beginning of
because he's gone through it like
passion you get Millennials if you look
at [ __ ] you we got this Yankee stuck
they don't even they don't know no they
don't
oh my family for the first time this
year in the beginning of the season
horrible rainy night but uh that was my
first time there I've watched so many
games at Fenway Hunt TV it was so
surreal I felt like I had been there
before
oh yeah when you're sitting in the thing
like when you're walking through and
trying to get food and then I go back
now it's not the ballpark I went to as a
kid I mean they got like a mall in the
right field to get people sitting up on
the Green Monster right it is so
different from when I left the green
moss which it didn't have any
advertising anything wrong I think it
looks way better with the advertising
and in early in Ted Williams days are
pre Ted Williams Dom DiMaggio days of
something I believe they they had
advertising there so it's gone through
like a bunch of stuff but dude I was
just thinking all this [ __ ] that I've
seen I've seen the Celtics in a game
seven with the Lakers seen the refs
called 30-something fouls on them and
like 15 on the Lakers in a game seven I
literally watched the Lakers beat us
from the foul line
and these weren't we wasn't without
their hacking people it was so [ __ ]
anticlimactic brutal I've seen too many
men on the ice I just
i-i've too many thing I don't give a
[ __ ] how many games were up until but
they hit also had it taken out of your
ball and you had the little snow plow to
give a thing for the college and the
crew every team has had those things all
of that [ __ ] I have to tell you that
deflate gate is up there with any like
as far as like the music man you could
redo the music man with the flaky if
they like the study literally found that
like the cults also had like three balls
that were slightly under inflated ESPN
did a study or is of course that showed
that the ball actually got there a
little bit later so it'd be an advantage
to the defense so of course they pulled
that immediately and a bunch of patched
fans had recorded it going like they
don't you know so why so why what
looking back now I feel like was it they
don't do they did something they [ __ ]
because we were in with with Goodell and
then something happened and that we were
just [ __ ] out I think part of it
wasn't I well I think part of it was
when they under suspended Ray Rice
uh-huh and they were just like yeah a
couple of games and then they tried to
say that they didn't see it then you
found out they saw it and then Goodell
he's making like 35 36 million dollars a
year then I think he just started over
suspending everybody and you think it's
like if we go after the Golden Boy
that'll kind of take the heat off of the
whole league know what I think what
ended up half the combination was that
and then we had some sort of falling-out
with a guy and then we took him to court
and in a court of law I mean it got
laughed out of court the judge actually
yelled at the NFL for wasting their time
really so a lot of people forget that so
then he played the next year not
suspended so then what you know now you
can't have double jeopardy he can't get
tried for the same thing so the NFL went
back and changed their argument and said
and said is the NFL a corporation and
they said yes and they says does a
corporation have a right to suspend
an employee if and they and they if they
feel fit and they said yes and they said
well Tom Brady is an employee of our
corporation and he is he is suspended
and they couldn't mess with that so
that's what we got
that's easy so he sat down for four
games because if Tom Brady and the
Patriots took the NFL to court and won
yeah and reversed it that was going to
open the floodgates every time helmet to
helmet head and suspension all this
could potentially you know how
corporation thinks like oh my god the
amount of money in legal costs will have
that nuts running on the nuthouse they
had to [ __ ] suspend them right so
that is my totally biased Patriots yeah
you know as far as like because we take
an air out of the ball we trying to
steal science yes as is everybody else
right which is why when you watch a
college football game my favorite thing
ever when you watch them when they send
in two signals there's like four guys
doing it right somebody's holding up a
picture of Oracle you know [ __ ]
pop-locking
you know and I also love to like the
whole idea that if you film somebody you
know what they're doing like they're
miming throwing the ball or handing it
off or punting it you still have to
figure it out and in as much as we
weren't guilty with the of the Spygate
thing I mean right if you're gonna sit
there and say oh yeah first of all
everyone else is pure well the thing
about that is is that was the first game
that that was illegal to do that would
even know wasn't know well that that was
legal you were allowed to Jimmy Johnson
even said he goes I came in the league
they said okay what am i doing I get a
camera pointed at their guy looking at a
half-time whatever you can steal steal
oh really so I think it just looked bad
after a while right so the rule was to
just that you couldn't have a guy on the
field you can still have a guy up in the
booth there is something called a zoom
lens they're still doing it yeah
everybody is still [ __ ] doing it so
it's funny yeah so if you're gonna spend
a mitt you're gonna say stealing Saye
dude then we should have to forfeit
World War two
do you have a college team that you like
were you like yes yes I have a bunch
that I like but LSU is my adopted one
that's your adopted I just loved the SCC
this was 10 years about 2008 I was after
Nick Saban was there right and I was
into Les Miles and you know he would
keep it just do that ship you know it
was almost like he was his offensive
mind was where the people in the upper
deck was whether like go and he would
just do it yeah and it worked for a
little while the LSU they're better yeah
their big thing is they've never been
since I've been watching them they
haven't had a quarterback that they've
believed in enough to let him play the
full game and they are literally playing
a lot of times this stereotypical like
old-school stereotypical white
quarterback black quarterback thing
where it's like it's a passing down Oh
get the white guy in there right it's so
running Lee we could maybe run the
option here get the black guy in there
and it's just like dude that's a lair
yes pick one and let them get into the
feel of the game as it be like hey Tom
that's why I never liked hosting yeah
cuz it's like you get him going to get
him going then you got to bring somebody
up at such an art and then you sit down
you [ __ ] you know thinking about your
day the next day it's like oh [ __ ] I got
to run back up and do another five
minutes yeah yeah my favorite thing in
hosting was we're gonna get we're gonna
keep the show moving right along and
bring the next guy up I'm not gonna do
any time in between
alright we're gonna keep this so much
just murders I'm just gonna keep the
show going yeah I kinda I really like
how this Comedy Store doesn't have a
host I really like yeah like they just
bring everything up you just bring each
other on I didn't I didn't think I was
gonna like that it's it's pretty awesome
oh you want to have a place that just
turned around no I don't know I was
living out here in the late 90s and when
you went down to the comedy store I mean
also no one knew who I was I was
struggling to get spots but that place
first of all there was nobody there no
spooky yeah and it was like all to the
vibe I first was like it was like I was
like a [ __ ] haunted house like you
went in there and then
all of these guys these guys that were
on TV and they were big names and they
would come in and just burn the light
they would just stand there
yeah having not done the work no didn't
write anything new I would just stand in
there and lean against the mic stand
yeah so what else is going on but bla
bla bla bla bla and you're sitting back
there you know your spots push back 5
minutes 10 minutes 40 minutes an hour
and a half two hours I'm going home I
can't go home if I go home they don't
know me
so I you just have to would have to
[ __ ] stay there Brewed and and all
these young kids were learning someday
when I get on his show I'm gonna do that
and I remember being here in 98 it was
right as Seinfeld was wrapping up and
Jerry the first time ever all these
years I had been out there he popped in
at the improv and I was like holy [ __ ]
it's the King right and he went on stage
was supposed to do 15 minutes he did 15
minutes right he started with the killer
joke he ended with a great joke and even
better joking in the middle he tried out
his new stuff and I just I just clicked
I was like that's the way you do it
that's a [ __ ] pro right and that
other [ __ ] is just ego and oh that's all
I got is showing him oh yeah yeah no
that place was spook I remember going
there mister back then and it was like
this is not gonna help me I think this
is gonna make me depressed it really was
it was hostile and I remember there was
a couple rays of light over there Rogan
I remember meeting Rogan for the first
time - laughs factory and I wrote over
yetsko she had this [ __ ] bad-ass cool
cars that's really what I remember about
those days was just watching Joe come in
a really cool car like wow that guy's
really got it going on yeah sick-ass
tailfin it was some sort of Japanese
sports car yeah I can't remember
so some turbo powered something we went
over there and it's this and he
basically gave me like a pep talk oh
yeah on the mindset you hit but it
wasn't spit wasn't specifically pointed
at the Comedy Store it was just the LA
comedy scene right right
like how you
to be don't [ __ ] listen anybody get
in there do your job and just like it
was like a real like it was like a
eight-point Power Joe Rogan's PowerPoint
thing that's great on the mindset and
that like and he was like a he was young
yeah Joe so he was like it was like is
this guy gonna like help me a [ __ ]
rip my head off like he was like the
most amped up dude I'd ever [ __ ] been
around and fortunately he turned out to
be like just a sweetheart of a guy yeah
and really the kind of the heart of what
turned that place around like he I'll do
him calling out [ __ ] machine and all
that like doing it was like it was it
was [ __ ] ridiculous was like coming
in there with a big can of raid just
spraying it all across the whole comedy
story it was unbelievable because like
the terror that you had yeah usually
they eat pulled in he pulled in the
thing you're like [ __ ] I'm going on next
right and all the work you wanted to do
you could not do you could not [ __ ]
do them I mean I want to start that [ __ ]
up again but like it's amazing now I
mean when you walk in there now it's
just just the original room just to go
and have a place to really work like you
really are gonna get work done
yeah what's funny is look at rogue look
how big Rogan is and what does he do he
doesn't like Seinfeld u15 he goes up he
does 15 tries out the [ __ ] he wants try
out he kills yeah you know we'll still
work on your stuff and go but it's
amazing though that usually wants a
place or a scene goes bad like that it's
very rare that it comes yeah yeah it's a
movie and a movie that happens I know
but to triumphs over evil
yeah but similar to what you were saying
about the seller being like that special
room and something just happens there
places have something to them you know
the Laugh Factory is always gonna be the
Laugh Factory the seller is always gonna
be the seller you know what I mean like
you know it's unreal mechanic may you
may dip and have bad times but that room
is begging to be good again yeah you
know the one I remember way back in the
day in the 90s when we were coming up if
you on the nine o'clock show Saturday
night at the comic strip oh my god
I made it was so it was like you'd come
off and think you were the greatest
comedian of all time yes I'm ready
yeah that room the energy of that square
room that centered stage yeah it was
unreal yeah on that one and that room
and that's a club that's that's gone in
the toilet and it's just waiting to come
back you put the right person booking it
and start attracting the good guys back
again because that room the architecture
the energy when human beings are in it
it's waiting to be if I was still in New
York I would still go there even if it's
going through a bad period it's just
like just to keep it going yeah run you
gotta use use whatever juice you have to
keep because how does that help comics
if there's one less room forget about a
room like that which through that that
room was [ __ ] crazy crazy crazy do
you remember who in the where the name
was the team red Johnny and the round
guy Oh God when they would go up at the
comic strip oh I mean my to follow him
at the [ __ ] Boston Comedy Club
nothing was bigger
nothing was bigger that they would just
rip the roof off that place I mean do
you know like one night when they used
to be down to the [ __ ] boss the
comedy club and they and they would do
the [ __ ] it takes two it gets to make
a thing go right and what I was going
and then remember Matt Frost who's now
at CIA he would be flicking the lights
[ __ ] on and off like it was a
nightclub and the place would be going
nuts there was some joke it was some
joke that they did yeah about going to a
dance club and feeling like an [ __ ]
and they just like when they went into
that bit it was like you were at a [ __ ]
is like you started watching a movie
yeah and you'd never just stand there
going like I have nothing nothing
nothing in my arsenal my whole career
never could take all of it and slam it
together I have nothing that could
follow that and I oh my god and going up
in that [ __ ] room after those guys
and bombing was the loneliest [ __ ]
thing like I mean I if I ever saw going
start crying
that I wouldn't even judge him and that
was back to when the club where all the
comics sat in the back packed but you
had to walk to the front of the stage
and go up in the middle before they had
that side yes and they would just be
back there and I remember I was this new
kid came down from Boston nobody gave a
[ __ ] yeah I remember running into Todd
Barry going like going like how do I get
in here like asking that [ __ ]
question with there is no answer how do
I get in at the club's I don't know what
he was thinking like hey dude
I'm trying I'm still trying to get it
you know and you'd sit back there and
you'd watch like a tel and Kevin Brandon
all these guys that were like already
made men like in and everybody had an
edge there was no like joy of like come
on along I'll show you the way no I was
just mean tough guys who got a spot and
you weren't taking it from them and
screw you
stayed till two o'clock in the morning
and let me I dare you to complain yeah I
dare you and there was a bunch of comics
who used to hide up town because they
didn't want to go downtown I think they
went down there once it takes to [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I am NOT going below [ __ ]
23rd Street and it was scary up there it
was it was like Armageddon and the but I
used to walk by the Boston during the
day when it had that [ __ ] red awning
yeah that look turned pink yeah it looks
like an old Peep Show bill [ __ ] front
I used to I used to get sick to my
stomach when I would look at it now and
I didn't that was the node-red
what I was just like I have to get over
this [ __ ] feeling or I am NOT gonna
make it in the no city I know cuz that
is [ __ ] now I'm just walking by the
building and it's like that bully I have
to fight yes completely I remember
saying to Kevin Brennan we stand up New
York and he's like it was talking just
about this and I said yeah but you know
we got to keep going because it's making
us stronger right we got to go cause
make us stronger
everything goes it's it's comedy I mean
how [ __ ] strong do we have to be
I remember this comic to [ __ ] and say
that this ship there should be no
heckling this should be no heckling he's
like you go to a Broadway show
there's no heckling and I don't wanna be
like whoa [ __ ] go go
[ __ ] get a job on Broadway then dude
because I don't think that there should
be any heckling that's like I think
that's what makes stand-up so [ __ ]
cool is that yeah that it's actually you
know that's part of it that somebody is
going to do that yeah that there's the
energy that something's good that this
is going to be different tonight than it
was last night and I don't see because
of me maybe because the audience maybe
because of the moon who knows and the
fact that people heckle is also what
keeps a lot of people from never weaves
out a lot of people yeah which is a gun
both on both sides yeah I don't to keep
you here too long I know you're onto it
a bunch of other podcast to promote your
show here all day well also we want to
have enough time for gonna Frick cigar
maybe who knows
start one finish it at home yeah you
could do that all right let's do that
let's do that Tom papa the show's called
baked it comes on September September
3rd Labor Day night 20 day 2 episode
starts 10 o'clock East 10 o'clock on
September 3rd and it's gonna run every
Monday through September the first one
is the first one actually is New York
and ok my buddy our buddy
Jim Gaffigan stops by a doughnut shop
while I'm there oh that's awesome
yeah it's great all right I've already
pitched myself for the second season I
came all right dude so happy for your
success buddy thank you buddy I'd see
the vest all right okay now it's time
for the reads here I apologize to all
the people that wrote in about the
farmers down there and South Africa I'm
going to read up on that and I will read
the rest of that guy's email on Thursday
okay that's my promise now if you know
me I'm scatterbrained so I might forget
okay but I don't take innocent people
dying anywhere lightly hit end them to
do it that and do it the other [ __ ]
all right with that let's do some reads
here Oh mint mobile Oh what do you get
gum when you [ __ ] Philip you can't
eat mint
the big in big wireless provider stands
for a lot of things big contracts big
bills big fees big pain and the 4k HD
what big Wireless doesn't want you to
know is that there's a way to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month introducing mint mobile the
game-changing company that takes
everything entered what that's taken
everything oh sorry wrong with big
wireless and made it right there
Crusaders MIT mobile makes it so easy to
cut your wireless bill down to just 15
bucks a month use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan okay these guys
aren't like separate-but-equal they're
not going down the South Air in the
1960s and 50s
they're user-friendly here you can use
your own phone with any mint mobile
plant you can keep your old number along
with all your existing contacts choose
between 2 5 or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans
every plan comes with unlimited talk and
text Jesus Christ I'm gonna get this
unlimited talk and text and if you're
not a hundred percent satisfaction
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their 7 day money-back guarantee
well when does the [ __ ] bill come
comes once a month how does that work
thanks to mid mobile Wireless never has
to be expensive again and to prove that
to prove that mint mobile is going to
hook you up you're gonna hook up 10 of
my listeners with free wireless for a
year holy [ __ ] seriously free wireless
for a year enter to win one year of mint
mobile service with 5 gigabytes of data
per month 10 potential winners will be
drawn from eligible entries receive
between August 27th and September 10th a
and you write me if you win it because I
want to make sure that they give us all
10 winners will be announced September
15th 2018 visit mint mobile.com / / be
you are our for your chance to win
and for the complete official rules mint
mobile.com / burr no purchase is
necessary and open to legal residents of
the 50 United State US states in the
District of Columbia you must be 18
years or older at time of entry all
right now Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks EF TFS is whatever the [ __ ] those
are options and kryptos crypto Neos all
Commission free what a kryptos what are
you investing in [ __ ] robots in the
future you creep they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just the wealthy pigs non
non-intimidating way for stock market
and newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence now the stock
market is just like gambling in Vegas
only play with money you can afford to
lose alright
simple and intuitive clear design with
data presented in an easy to digest way
values of the Robin Hood app are as
follows cost / no Commission fees other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees fee trade fees trade
stocks and keeps and keep all your
profits sorry I could read that a little
more clearly other brokers charge up to
10 bucks for every trade but Robin Hood
doesn't charge Commission fees trade
stocks and keep all of your profits
everybody it's easy to use easy to
understand and charts and market data
place a trade in just four taps on your
smart phone Robin Hood web platform also
lets you view stock collections 100 most
populous sectors like entertainment
social media and curating categories
like female CEOs for a little reverse
sexism there but you know they female
CEOs probably need help right help out
the ladies and invest in their companies
provide it's a good company you know the
end of the day you can be part of a
cause but it's your money dear and
analysts analysts ratings of buy / hold
/ sell for every stock learn how to
invest in build your portfolio
Robin Hood is giving less listeners a
free stock like Apple wait Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free a free stock
like Apple Ford or Sprint to help build
your portfolio that's hilarious
they're undercutting Sprint and letting
you invest in them so they're good guys
sign up at Bill Burke
Robin Hood calm that's Bill burr dot
Robin Hood calm I read it wrong the
first time
bill bar dot Robin Hood calm all right
oh look who's back in doji don't talk
about how every man looks better in a
suit I don't know how to do this anymore
you know what every man looks good in a
suit no matter how long that tie is
dangling between their junk the end of
the day they look better than the
walking around you know he's a thing you
want to meet a woman okay you got to
take respect in the way you dress all
right and I know you want to be that guy
dressed down Friday all the friggin time
but I'm telling you you put on a little
habit - Sheree they're all right they
take a bus but you show a little respect
for yourself and the ladies will notice
you know I wonder if they make like
those power suits that Hillary Clinton
wore for the ladies I have no idea
additional copy points friendo Chino is
that it's the world's largest made to
measure men's wear company and it's been
featured in major publications including
GQ Forbes and something called fast
company they make suits and shirts made
to your exact measurements for great fit
guys love will love the wide selection
of high quality fabrics and the option
to personalize all the details including
your lapel lining and monogram okay this
is like Conor McGregor's [ __ ] for
someone like myself who doesn't out of
fight how great does Conor McGregor look
at every way or whatever whenever he's
sitting there talking [ __ ] about
everybody killing it better than most
comics I know the man always looks well
why he always looks great because he has
designer suits you could do it too
here's how it works visit a showroom or
shop online indogene Oh calm pick your
fabric choose your customers
submit your measurements wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks and then you got a custom suit so
if you show up where everybody else has
a suit on they just bought it off the
rack they don't got their initials there
then I've got that snazzy lining that
you're gonna have right visit a showroom
or shop online an endo chino calm this
week my listeners can get any premium
indochina
suit for just 379 bucks and endo Chino
com
that's probably well how much does
[ __ ] Conor McGregor's pocket square
cost but you're working your way up when
entering burr at checkout that's fifty
percent fifty percent off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
plus shipping is free that's Indo Chino
comp promo code for any premium super
necessary nine dollars is incredible
deal for a suit that will fit you better
than anything off the rack ever will
alright but do biondi's me undies
they're killing all the [ __ ] farmers
dudududu be IDs be on these and then
they go get some shwarma they're takin
the land back that was stolen from
[ __ ] innocent people where does it
end at least your balls will be nice and
soft when they come in with the [ __ ]
machetes me undies sorry you've
definitely heard me talk about me undies
I just rhymed farmers with shwarma
that's not bad huh I showed a little
[ __ ] M&M there you know he had Ben's
the [ __ ] word alright bill it didn't
rhyme whatever I thought it's pretty
good on the fly you know the fun comfy
undies that feel as good as they look to
those you haven't tried them yet listen
up you get incredible underwear sent to
your door with me undies meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually cease
settling for good enough just picture
you walking around your skivvies drop in
trial is it try always always drop in
trout for the longest time but it's
trial like you're putting you take it
down your trousers which always reminds
me of that louis c.k joke when he was
talking about calling up a phone sex
line and you'd always get that old woman
talking dirty to him I'm gonna take off
your trousers
some jokes just stick with me meaning no
more hunting around for the blah blah
blah blah me Andy
are made with a sustainably sourced
material from beechwood trees this is
how confident these guys are they're
putting trees in their underwear and
somehow it's still more comfortable than
cotton this naturally soft fiber makes a
fabric that won't sag down or rip trust
me I got prepared these that all of this
is true once you put on a pair you're
gonna get it and if you're already part
of the me undies fam not family fam
they're trying to meet you they're
trying to reach the Millennials on that
line when you're part of the me undies
fam yo tell your friends about it
through their referral program they'll
get a discount and you'll get a store
credit it's a win-win still not sure
what else do I gotta tell you well the
undies has a deal for my listeners
first-time purchasers get 15% off their
first pair immune DS and shipping is
free that's 50% off free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your me undies
will be very happy together get your ass
over to me undies comm and treat
yourself to get 15% off your first pair
and free shipping 100 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee go to the undies
comm / / that's my undies comm / /
alright two more hang in there hang in
there oh it's all zip hiring used to be
hard I don't know multiple job sites
stacks a resumes a confusing review
process Jesus Christ where does it end
but today hiring can be easy and you
only have to go to one place to get it
done zip recruiter dot-com / / when you
go to zip they send you your zip
recruiter sends your jobs to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards they don't
stop there
most people would stop there but not zip
recruiter but they're powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of job resumes to find people with the
right experience and invite them to
apply for your position as applications
come in zip analyzes each one of them
and
spots lights the top candidates so you
know you don't have to [ __ ] around with
people who aren't qualified so you never
miss a great match
zip recruit is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day time is money
zip recruiter understands this with
results like that it's no wonder why zip
is the highest-rated hiring site in
America and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at the
exclusive web address zip recruited comm
slash bird that zip recruited comm / /
spell out / ok bu RR once again that zip
zip recruiter dot-com / / zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire and lastly but
certainly not least Lee the headliner of
all my advertising for most part
stamps.com
they've been with me since the beginning
the US Postal Service is an important
tool for any business stamps.com is the
easiest way to access all the amazing
services of the post office
stamps.com never closes print postage
for letters or packages at your
convenience 24/7 right your wife went to
bed your kids are in bed you're gonna
get a jump on your day you pour yourself
a scotch and your printouts of goddamn
postage print postage for any mail class
right from your own computer the exact
amount excuse me the exact at the
hiccups the exact amount of postage
every time never under pay for over pay
again stamps.com saves you time and
money which you can use to grow your
business buying print official US
postage this is getting redundant for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer
they'll send you a digital scale it
automatically calculates the exact
postage the post office and all their
wonderful [ __ ] that they do down there
is now in your house stamps.com will
even help you decide the best class of
mail for your needs you can do it in the
nude no need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments I use stamps comb to send
out all my posters which I really need
to advertise
better I have autographed posters these
amazing posters that people have told me
I could sell for 40 bucks at a show but
you know what I'm a man of the people
all right I only sell them for 20 bucks
their autograph they're right every one
of my goddamn shows and people keep
walking out and then they text me after
hey man I wanted to see the poster where
is it it's out there in the lobby I
don't know where
all right I'm sidetracked but I used
stamps.com to send these [ __ ] out all
right stamps calm I use stamps talk I
just told you why and right now you too
can enjoy stamps calm the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus postage
and a digital scale go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr that
stamps.com enter burr alright by the way
as I mentioned before my great buddy
Dean del Rey he's doing his first talk
show as a stand-up comedian tonight
Monday night on Conan O'Brien with the
great and brilliant
Marc Maron is one of the guests please
tune in and and check it out and after
that it says I got a ton of mails ton of
emails of us from South Africa so I have
to read these I can at least read the
rest of this guy this thing here I
figure out where I left off let's just
pick this up which brings me to my
second point now I don't follow all the
news on Trump frankly I don't care
anymore because it's exhausting I agree
I agree to everybody's screaming and
yelling flipping the [ __ ] out and nobody
has a solution but the message I get
from the media is still the same they
hate him and will blow up any small
thing just to take him down and
basically you know something that is a
problem in this country ever since Bill
Clinton no one has been allowed to be
president without being constantly under
attack and I really think it hurts the
position Democrat Republican or
libertarian whatever you gotta let the
person try to do the [ __ ] job you
know anyways they hate him and will blow
up anything you dedicate basically
they're saying Trump has chosen debate
team a
therefore we will choose opposing team B
that is true
with CNN and Fox they both do it
everybody is making a big deal over
every bombshell in quotes in the Muller
probe of he must have known and this
lawyer knew about that [ __ ] and pleaded
guilty really do you want to tell me
Hillary Clinton or any other politician
would have the same kind of I think even
wanted to say wouldn't have the same
kind of dirty Hillary would have been
getting attacked the entire [ __ ] time
they all played dirty I would never have
expected it otherwise so my point is
yeah but they don't all play dirty
Bernie Sanders did not play dirty
which why I don't think it's a waste of
a vote to even though the guy's not
gonna win to a vote for somebody like
that because you're trying to encourage
more people by seeing the amount of
votes that you can get by being a good
[ __ ] person I think people say you've
wasted your vote anyways
so my point is Trump actually noticed a
problem in South Africa that requires
attention but we probably won't get the
attention we need because the dumbass
media is too busy writing South Africa
hit back at Trump articles that's true
they try to take down everything that
he's doing but the thing about it is is
he only seems to notice problems that
hit white people okay that's the [ __ ]
problem
okay and and in as much as our media
definitely would have attacked any
Republican that went in there the the
left-wing media would definitely do that
I mean I think when you look at
neo-nazis and go yeah well I mean did
you know people were being aggressive on
both sides you kind of lose a lot of
credibility is all I'm saying all right
but I understand also what you're saying
okay continuing Wow you read it all the
way up to here Thanks go be an
inspiration to all the other hairless
gingers out there alright so there's an
element from South Africa Bill Clinton's
balanced budget myth all right so it
wasn't balanced now I have to wonder
like where did this come from now is
this
people on the right yeah you don't know
where any this is from so now I'm just
supposed to read this and I'm supposed
to look at you and assume that yours
this guy down the middle that votes on
both sides I will I will read this you
guys are making me more informed I think
or maybe you're swaying me like that guy
who wrote in from Russia but I don't
know if that's the guy from Russia who's
hacked into the Twitter [ __ ] I don't
know where any of this shit's coming
from shark theft hey Bill just wanted to
share this ridiculous story about this
guy that stole a [ __ ] shark from an
aquarium in Texas he dressed the shark
as a baby and put it on a pushchair
and just walked out his justification
was he was concerned for the Sharks
welfare well he probably wanted to put
it back in the ocean but uh once he
takes it out of the water I think the
shark was like hey man I don't think
that aquarium was was so bad granted
it's not as big as the ocean and I'm no
longer to live freely as a living thing
on this planet but uh you know if the
shark went to rescue you and stuck you
dressed you as a baby and put you in a
[ __ ] carriage and then took you
underwater
I think you there is still some due
process in this country the fact that
the article says a man accused of
stealing shark I mean I think the fact
that he had it you know oh I thought
this was like I thought that was part of
the gift bag after you went to the
aquarium that you could take one of the
fish home all right
robin Leach Billie Ben's you're old
enough to remember lifestyles of the
rich and famous oh yeah yeah that was
great that's one of the first the sort
of MTV Cribs before MTV Cribs this guy
robin Leach and they glorified it and it
was just all like and when they're
sitting at their pool they just don't
[ __ ] it too pooled I eat escargot I love
watching it do an impression for the
kids who don't know what he sounded like
I can't do an impression of him I
haven't seen it long enough and I'm not
good at impressions unless the persons
in my life like I can imitate
I can imitate I'm working on a deen
dayal ray that I'm gonna get like he
always comes back from concert ain't
Dean how was it ah dude it was killer he
always goes down or if he's talking
about some of there's an [ __ ] oh that
guy okay
that guy's a garbage can all right the
first show to really give you a look at
how filthy rich some people are was the
lifestyles of the rich and famous I
remember seeing an onyx black bathtub
and just thinking that all rich people
had black sinks and bathroom fixtures
alright for those who didn't grow up in
the 80s if somebody had an all-black
bathroom they were into cocaine on an
entirely different level they were going
Kleinfeld
you remember Kleinfeld mom oh the most
underrated Sean Penn character of all
[ __ ] time car in Carlito's Way you
got to check that out where he was good
when I love when Pacino said that lie
Lauria